another season is upon us yes how are we
feeling about it I'm feeling anxious
I just am part of a tumultuous
relationship and you know just to kind
of see how everything plays out know how
it played out
Austin Kroll is talking about his
girlfriend of about a year Madison
Lacroix she joins the cast of southern
charm this season with a bang right out
the gate a video seen around the
internet makes its way to TV what is the
story behind that video because I don't
think we have gotten a clear description
of what was going down yeah I mean you
know okay so I guess that what I can say
is that that was like very early on in
Madison and I trying to figure out what
we were you know we both had you've done
the like you're my girlfriend and you're
mine right okay so as a pre DTR pre the
top yeah and like we definitely were
both you know trying to like push it to
see how much other person cared like I'm
gonna go out tonight and I'm not gonna
talk to her see if that you know bothers
her or vice versa
okay and so we had this talk right cuz
she's talking about the fact that her ex
wouldn't leave her alone and I was like
you told me to leave you alone I will
never like I'm I'm gone and we kind of
had one of those moments I was like fine
fine so I I busied myself and it didn't
turn out well you know because she
showed up you know the next day and was
like wait I want to talk things over and
you're like I'm busy I like but then
there's and I don't really know what
yeah he claims I don't remember any
without Oh
mind the mind like I you know but then
there's no apologies and forgiveness and
so on so clean slates that aren't that
clean and that's
the foundation of what you see this
season I like tough things the you know
can people actually get over things and
it just leads into other stuff and then
Shep and I were very Pro Austin which
you'll see we are I think you're a bad
influence on Austin did you think twice
about bringing a relationship to reality
TV yeah I did I knew that coming into
this season that you know it wasn't
gonna be an easy ride it's not gonna be
easy going so I kind of just prepared
the both of us like hey look you know
because we can control
I guess what we talk you know but I
can't control what they're saying in you
know behind our back to you know whoever
else right and I was like you know it's
not gonna be like Oh under Madison or a
wonderful you know and they're just so
cute together and I love them I was like
they're gonna be we're gonna be getting
trashed here for a little bit so that's
something that you know I mean it like
you want to try to be with somebody than
then you just work through it yeah
it's part of your life and it works out
sometimes and it does another time I
want to make this work
well as far as I know survived the first
season of filming with her yes the right
hip is intact today yes relationship is
in impact this one's different for me so
III is she the wine but see a lot Oh
Bryce asked me too hard I couldn't even
begin to you know I I take these cases
Dave tape high-tech ok he's gazes being
in my relationship and right now you're
happy it feels different than any
relationship before she's in a unique
situation that I've never been in before
with any girl that I've ever dated so
like I kind of follow her lead a lot
right cuz you know I mean she's got a
lot going on eg caught up with the guys
of southern charm at the King Charles
Anne in Charleston South Carolina where
they had this to say about what's to
come on season six of the Bravo hit
you'll find that week sort of let it fly
this season I felt like some of the
girls were very guarded and so if if
that makes us the villain then fine but
we we were we don't hold back now we put
it all out there like I mean the guys
especially but the three of us were
pretty I mean we're completely
transparent I think we yes we're like we
we what you'll see is what our lives
words are the fullest during that time
I mean Austin can speak a little to this
I mean you it took you a year to to
figure out the balance of how to you
know say what you mean but not you know
not be our I don't know if it's a
balancing yeah I think that the best
thing that I can say is that
transparency is is the best way to go
about doing this
and I you know ups and downs you know
it's not just like a happy-go-lucky time
[Music]